Mega Man 3 Mega Man explodes in back to back robot battle.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
I feel like it's worth clarifying that Mega Man does not explode in this game unless he dies.
He does if you're me.
Okay, yeah. Back to back explodes a lot if you're me.
Right, right. But I guess I meant like the back of the box shouldn't be like the headline is that Mega Man explodes.
I guess they meant Mega Man 3, like the game explodes.
Right, right. Yeah.
I thought that was weird too though.
I was like, are they advertising like how bad you're going to be at the game?
Yeah, don't put this cart in a toaster.
Put it in an NES or it will explode.
Or on a chair. Oh God, there it is.
Thank you. So early in the episode.
Okay, it's Mega Man 3 though.
And I feel like, you know, this is another one of those games that we just like, we just
know is important, even if we've never played it before.
I've never played this one before.
Have you guys played this one?
No. You know, I bet I had played it like in passing as a kid.
I remember playing multiple Mega Man games briefly as a kid.
So this could have been one of them.
I played, I remember playing 8.
I played the 2 for the podcast.
I think there was a couple X's in there.
Um, and, uh, that one 3D one where you kick a ball.
I feel like I probably said this in the Mega Man 1 episode, but it's worth, I mean, that
was how many years ago now.
I think it's worth just repeating that like I owned Mega Man X, the original on Super Nintendo,
and I love that game.
I thought it was great. And so as a result, I bought like one of those Mega Man anniversary collections on either PlayStation
2 or GameCube and, uh, never even got to Mega Man 3 because I was just stunned at how
hard these games were.
Uh, you know, like for, for a PS2 minded brain to go back to this NES stuff.
It was like, I can't, I can't make any progress in these games.
And I just, I don't think I played more than a half hour of Mega Man anniversary collection,
which is a shame because it's probably hours and hours of endless fun.
But the podcast forces me to play these games.
So we will be playing them Mega Man 1 and 2 both currently on the essential games list.
Feels like a huge feat, uh, that both of those, those games are on them, even when they're
offering the kind of the same exact product.
Uh, you know, it's not like, oh, they're different games.
Uh, they're, they're the same kind of game and Mega Man 3 is going to change the formula
a little bit. We'll get into it in the episode, but it's mostly the Mega Man.
We know it's Capcom, uh, pumping out these action platformers year after year after year.
It's, it's become a yearly cycle.
And essentially the, the, you know, the third main Mega Man game on the NES introduces, uh,
the slide mechanic and rush the dog, uh, his transformations.
Uh, so, you know, those are like the two big things, but otherwise like it's eight new
robot masters.
It's, uh, there's a new mid game chapter with this doc robot.
There's a robot character who, uh, actually has the abilities of the bosses from Mega Man
2. That's kind of cool.
There's a proto man who I think is known as break man in these games.
It's his introduction as well.
And he just kind of has his own little mini stage as well, which is, uh, a little lackluster,
but we'll get to that. And last but not least, Dr.
Wiley, uh, who is now completely reformed, uh, is working again with Dr.
Light. I asked the question, if you were someone who tried to take over the world via the power
of these robots twice.
And again, I don't know the politics of the Mega Man world, but if you announced that you're
reformed, shouldn't you go to like jail first?
You shouldn't just be able to like go back to working on robots.
I don't think jail is a thing in this universe.
There is no government at all is what you're saying.
Yeah. It's just robots and scientists and, uh, robots and scientists.
Yeah. Mega Man's a robot.
Is he fully?
Or I thought he was a cyborg.
He's a full clanker, man.
He is a robot.
Yeah. We prefer to call them bots on the show.
Uh, can I, can I re can I rewind a little bit and just talk about like our history with
this, with this series?
Yeah. I'm sorry that I didn't let you do that.
No, no, no. It's okay.
So I, you know, I don't do this often.
Usually it's one of you guys that like kind of tries to rejog your memory or you just keep
the memory from when we originally recorded and it doesn't like leak out of you like my
dumb brain. But, uh, I just wanted to, you know, kind of recenter where we have been on this.
And obviously we voted, we kind of unanimously voted these essential.
Um, but in both instances, Mike, you threatened or, or even just sort of like predicted that
Mega Man one would be removed.
Now the one that I did not listen to again was the best of 89 when you could have removed
one.
Did you, did you try and remove one like officially?
I don't think I tried to remove it.
I don't recall doing that.
Yeah. In one, you said, I see a future in which I have removed Mega Man one or we have removed
and in two, you're like, I don't know.
I might be coming at Mega Man one.
So it's actually, it's actually funny that we didn't at least have a discussion about
it. So I think it's, it's interesting coming back to it here, uh, because it's been a couple
before we get into the game and everything.
I want to just also, you know, tread some old ground here on Mega Man and just remind
everybody that, uh, the Mega Man loop is there's, uh, eight robot master stages.
You select any of them.
You can start where the game, wherever you want.
And whenever you defeat that robot, you win their weapon.
And now you can use, uh, that weapon on everything else in the game with a limited supply that
you can, uh, refill.
But like the idea is, is that you basically gain the power of one robot master and use
it as, uh, exploit its weakness on the other appropriate robot master to then have, uh, an
easier fight. Right.
And so there's, there's a known path of like, okay, if I, if I started this guy and just
continue to go around in, in a, uh, you know, in a predetermined path, I'll always have the
strongest weapon to make these fights a little bit easier.
And that works into the fact that in Japan, Mega Man's name is actually Rock Man.
And it's supposed to be like a rock, paper, scissors thing where like everything has a, a
weakness and a resistance.
And I, I feel like I understood that more with Mega Man one than I do now, because I, I looking
at the robot masters in the game, I don't think you can tell who's weak to who.
Like this is, this isn't rock, paper, scissors anymore.
This is like, okay, snake is weak to needle.
Like what, what's happening?
You know, like needle is, is needle to top man.
Like, you know, it's hard to figure out.
The idea that, uh, in Japan, his name is Rock Man changes things a little bit for me.
I, but to me, I never thought I knew about this rock, paper, scissors thing, but I never
thought of it like Pokemon where it's like, yes, snakes are weak to needles or whatever.
Whatever snake man's weak to, but more so that just like, snakes probably are weak to needles,
by the way. I mean, yeah, that would actually be pretty, uh, I think they're weak to most of the things
that Mega Man acquires.
Yeah. But I, I just thought of it more as like, not so much like, oh, you're supposed to be
discovering like their, in their, um, intuitive weaknesses as opposed to just like, oh, like
this, the, the one guy's flying up there and there just happens to be a thing that lets
you shoot at that angle.
Like that. I never thought of it like, oh, you're supposed to know.
I just thought of it more like, oh, if you have that thing, it's going to make it easier.
Like it's, I never thought of it like Pokemon, you know, I just thought of it more like,
oh, I wonder what, uh, this, this.
You'll experiment and then you'll figure out like, oh, this actually makes sense.
Yeah. Sorry. I'm fumbling over my words here, but like, yeah, I'm on a boss and I'm having a really difficult
time. Hey, maybe I'll come back after I've gotten a couple more weapons and try one of those and
see if they work on them and knowing that one of them will.
Yeah. I mean, that's an important note because it doesn't, you don't have to have the most powerful
weapon to take on any of these bosses.
You can complete every single one of these bosses with just the, um, the normal blaster.
So there's no reason to think that, uh, it's, you know, it's, it's not encouraged by the game,
at least to like know the optimal path.
I feel like the only way to know the optimal path is by talking with other gamers and figuring
out like, oh, this weapon did this amount of damage.
Cause it's not even like, it's not even straightforward in the sense of they're only, they only each
have one weakness.
Uh, magnet man is weak to the spark, the shadow blade and the magnet.
So it's not like he, they can't, uh, there, there aren't multiple paths, you know, there,
there's any way to handle it.
I feel like it comes from play testing.
Interestingly enough, like the levels themselves and figuring out like, well, who is the easiest
to like defeat and start this game off.
So I have at least one additional, uh, powered up weapon at my disposal.
Yeah. And it's not even always, at least for me about an actual weakness where like this thing is
going to do more damage to this enemy.
Sometimes for me, it was like, I don't know if you'd call it like accessibility or something,
where it's just like, like the example I used a minute ago, an enemy that's flying up in
the air the whole time.
I need a, something that's going to be able to reach him better.
You know, even if it doesn't do more damage, it's some of it's to me more about like the,
the trajectory of the projectile or, or, or the actual function of it and not just like
the damage output on this person.
Yeah. And we have really interesting, uh, powers this time around.
Uh, there are some that are just basically stronger blasters, but I mentioned the needle,
uh, cannon that goes through walls.
So you kind of like are able to hit enemies, uh, that, and not all walls, but it goes through
walls that you're able to hit enemies on the other side of things.
That's where you can take care of them before you have to approach them closely or the, uh,
laser, uh, beam that, uh, can, you know, bounce off the walls and everything.
So you can hit enemies that are higher up without having to get close to them.
And then there's the spin in place.
Yes. The top spin.
It feels like something that must be incredibly strong because it's incredibly useless.
Otherwise, like it must have a time and a place.
I remember trying like, you know, I'll try it out during the level, uh, like on the next
level. I don't know how you guys, uh, strategically use your power ups, but like, I'll give it a shot
just so I know what I'm doing with it.
And I'm like, wow, I just, I just spin.
You're just, you just, I just spin.
And I tried it against an enemy like, oh, maybe I can do like some actual like melee damage
for once. And I just kept taking damage while I'm spinning.
So I, I, you know, I just thought it was kind of useless except for during the boss.
Yeah. That was recommended next.
I didn't even really use it during the boss.
I did watch a video of someone actually like completely annihilating a boss with it, but
uh, I never found it useful in any of my, like, uh, like I never naturally decided to
use it and found it useful.
So my understanding of how it works is, and it's a little technical here and I don't have
the technicality to explain it, but apparently whatever I frames are, I don't know what they
are. I'm so sorry. Mega Man, uh, doesn't have them.
So the top spin.
Invincibility frames. Okay, great.
So Mega Man doesn't have them.
So if the top spin does, let's say, um, four bars of damage to it, to a particular boss,
every single frame of it counts.
So it could do the entirety of the life bar in a single top spin, uh, because it's counting
every frame that it connects to the hit box, uh, which makes some fights very trivial,
but it doesn't work on everything.
There are some enemies that are just immune to, uh, some of these weapons, not just the
top spin, but other weapons too.
There's nothing you can do about that.
And, and I think it makes sense if top spin doesn't work on hard man, right?
I presume a hard man has strong resistance to a lot of things.
He should, he should be, uh, yeah, exactly.
He's, he's hopefully has a strong armor or something, but it, it was interesting that like the
best part of this game does remain these power-ups that you get, uh, for beating these, uh,
these bosses early on, because I feel like somehow this is just like new shmup power-ups
in, in, in like those shmup kind of games, but they always find a way to like redefine the game a
little more in this platforming context than I'm, than I'm ever expecting, uh, other platformers to do,
you know, like other platformers, I feel like would give you the ability to jump higher or create a
platform. And like Mega Man has those options as well, but the power-ups that he gains by switching
these weapons makes all these weapons like incredibly useful and still three iterations in like still
interesting. It's not like, Oh, they're, they ran out of ideas here.
Cause like snakes is a weird idea.
I would think that like snakes can't work as like, you can't get snakes as a power-up.
What's he gonna do? Shoot snakes out of his cannon.
That's exactly what he does.
Little snakes come out, but they crawl
along the screen and they can ride all the edges of the wall so they can hit areas that like enemies
hug that you can't reach.
And that's perfect. That's a great use of snakes.
! Sorry to
Sorry Sorry so that's the combat there is one other major change and that is the slide mechanic uh this
is the first game to introduce it i feel like that would be weird to go back to megaman one
and two now without a slide because you you're forced to use it a lot like they definitely want
to teach you that it's useful and there are certain enemies where like sliding is optimal
instead of trying to jump over them or um or go under them it's the slide is the preferred
mechanic but is the slide is the slide like a is it an added skill thing or is it like a necessary
thing now that they've included in the game of like well you you have to slide because they design
things around sliding whereas like you know oh sliding also has this flare element to it can it
be both i think it's necessary at least in uh they're trying very hard to teach you that it
will be necessary beyond just like oh this is the you you can only get here via sliding i think that's
just like a reminder to use it but like there's times in the i don't know bolt electro uh volt i
don't know what the the electric guy that one shot man or whatever yeah like where you're you got like
some timing stuff that you're gonna have to or the one with uh the the walls that just kind of get
built up over time um really fast like you're gonna want to slide through that because it's sort of like
it's a timing thing and then there are enemies that have attack patterns that are just high enough that
you can slide under them it would be like crouching if that ever existed in mega man and so i i think
it is like you can you can take the damage i guess and just do and just go about it that way but if
you're trying to conserve energy for bosses and stuff but uh then you're gonna want to be sliding
yeah it's also just like it's there are a lot of situation where it's really it's just really good
movement tech i guess where like you don't need to be doing it but it does you do move a little
faster you it does it is a good dodge so even in times where the game is not designed where it's
like oh you have to slide here a lot of times it was useful a lot of times i found it more useful
in jumping you know and then other times yeah i thought it was pretty really only in addition i
never felt like uh it was like uh they're just trying to force me to do this shoehorn and in you know
again like sean said obviously there's a lot of times where you do have to use it but i think it
is yeah this also just like uh hey get used to doing this because you're it's going to be helpful
if you do you know you also have the dog now yeah you have rush uh and we had in mega man 2 like uh
there were uh additional power-ups that you could uh acquire to like have some kind of platforming
mobility but rush now like puts a character behind that mega man's of course robot dog every every
robot needs a man's best friend robo dog as well and rush has the um the springboard the um like the
the jet uh that he transforms into that you kind of ride as like a hoverboard and then the one i didn't
understand for a long time because you you summon it and it immediately says nope i'm not supposed to be
here but it is for uh it's a submarine for the water uh parts of levels when you get into him
yeah you get inside him which uh don't don't say that part again uh and all that to say like i i
think it actually does become more than just like a cool new character i do think like between the coil
which becomes very useful and very obvious that like they want you to use it in certain places to
like get cool power-ups or one-ups and such uh the jet really becomes like a uh an easy way to like
as long provided that you keep the uh i don't want to call it ammunition but everything has like its own
power gauge provided you keep that filled uh you can skip a lot of like hard enemies in these regular
uh regular stages just by using the jet to kind of like lift you up over them and get to the ladder that
you need to reach uh which can be useful if you're dying um and need to like conserve energy because
the bosses uh you know are harder you haven't learned their patterns yet but i guess he's also a good
boy yeah i guess i i found it like it was it was good design i guess that there is a point if you're going
in the order i went in um there's a point where you cannot proceed unless you use him and i didn't
know that i had even unlocked him yet because i didn't read the manual for this it's also meant
that i had no idea what was actually going on in the story for a long time but that's
either here nor there but uh you you have to use uh the dog jump and i didn't you know i pause and i
don't see a dog jump and i was pressing button combinations because i remember like oh yeah in
the in the art the dog's there and i remember this is like a thing in in newer games too um and in i
think smash where you jump on them but so then you realize that even like before you've unlocked
anything there this is on the second page so i it was a an interesting moment of like okay i just have
to navigate a menu a couple menus deep to use this jump which kind of takes some of the energy out of
it but it's there yeah now that you mentioned it a little strange that it like starts out on the
second page when it's like the first thing you get but um yeah it's not i it never got to a point
to me where it was it felt like it's part of the platforming like twitch reflex gameplay it felt more
like a little more like cognitive you need to stop and think it's almost like a puzzle solving moment
whenever you need to use the dog very simple puzzle but yeah you gotta like right you gotta like jingle
in your pocket to grab this tool yes exactly and we mentioned also the introduction of proto man
note is break man in this game uh he has a really cool whistle that plays before he ever shows up
and i feel like uh that adds a lot of personality to him maybe a bit of mystery who is this guy
uh but the actual like fights are really poor in my opinion especially for a mega man game where like
the attack patterns and learning them is like half the fun uh he just he just jumps around the stage
not even knowing if you're in front of him or not i feel like it's funny that you say that like oh
it's so mysterious and then it's as if like there is a second player that is just spamming jump and it
feels less like ai and more like a kid that's never played a video game before well yeah i almost wonder
if that maybe not not literally that but if that was the intent where it's like this is supposed to feel
like another mega man like a haunted game and it's kind of like the game is handed yeah look at this is what
you look like now that's funny uh but he shows up several times not even in like some of the regular
stages he'll show up as like a mid boss or whatever but like it's weird that he shows up and does the
same thing every time like i feel like i kind of expected that in the regular uh stages uh the robot
master stages that like okay yeah it's just the same fight because that's what he does but when you get
that after you take down um the robot master stages and the doc robot stages you get like this icon in
the center that's just like his icon and it's like oh shit we're going to his lair now but it's just a
fight with him uh on one screen and he continues to do the same thing and i tried a few different like
power-ups to come at him with but i feel like the game was also leading me in this direction where it's
just best to use the power uh the regular blaster and slide under him whenever he jumps uh like in
your direction you just slide directly under him and keep firing from his back it's a very easy fight
once you realize that you just have to not interact with him yeah yeah or find the cheese yeah what i was
hoping for out of proto man what i wish there was is like every time you get a new power-up he gets a new
unrelated power-up like he's on his own journey getting his own power-ups but then every time you
fight him he it's gonna be different i think that's so cool and i i i guess i just like i don't want to
make the game any longer either so i wasn't suggesting like a a a break man level in that
center icon it just felt like a big moment in the game where like okay you've taken down all the robot
masters and usually you would go to the wily castle at this point but instead you have to have this
mini fight with uh break man again and it just turns out to be the same exact fight it it felt
like a misstep because the the up until this point in the game everything had been kind of
from a from a design perspective like what we expect of mega man there's new power-ups which is cool
the slide is a interesting like platforming mechanic but but mostly like if you were good at mega man one
and two uh you know you're you're gonna be good at this one too and just gradually like get better at
it as you learn the pacing switches once you get to the uh wily castle stuff which spoiler alert guy
didn't reform he's evil as hell just like he always was and nobody should trust people who say that
they've reformed if they've committed like crimes against society i guess like maybe they need to do
some time before they're ready to re-enter society i don't know what that says i don't know what the
lesson is there but what i do know is that once you get to the wily castle in previous games this
was my demise uh whether it was mega man one or mega man two but especially mega man two uh like wow
i in mega man two i just could not uh make good progress uh in wily's castle and i never got to see
the end unless i was cheating in mega man three it's a little bit of a reverse i feel like wily castle
is like shorter levels broken up like a lot quicker and uh the uh yeah there's some annoying
things like they still include the boss rush and um the mega man hologram stage also kind of sucks
but like for the most part they are like shorter tighter levels that are really just about fighting
like fun bosses that aren't robots after you've fought uh 12 total robot masters across the doc robots
and the uh and the regular stages it it was like a it was a reverse mega man two i feel like mega man
two had really good regular stages and then the wily castle was like near impossible here i felt like
it was reversed what about you guys well i would like to first just uh reply to what joe said about um
how what he how he thought proto man should be built um and i would just say that if they're gonna make
uh proto man power ups uh you gotta give the player you gotta give the player that that power
up at some point right like that's that's just that's just 101 right so that i don't know i don't think so
okay um but that that's how i would feel about that in terms of the uh the sort of level structure here
i like you know one and two uh did not beat this game uh i i don't have uh i i don't have the
endurance to get good at these games so i played the i played all of the original eight levels um and
then like saw some of the the the the next four which are just like harder versions of those levels so
i was never gonna get past that anyway but i i think like if we're gonna if we're talking about this
the it's not so much a reverse it's that like it's also you've got that extra padding in there
which is taking all of the difficulty from like the wily stuff from the previous games
and just sort of putting it in the middle of this one and now you've got like this weird
like bell curve of diff of difficulty uh in the game so it's just like a different sequence
yeah that makes any sense no i can i can hear you on that because i think that's a good point that i
probably should have made is that yeah from like a pacing perspective i just feel like those doc robot
stages which i kind of glossed over but you accurately said are just like remix stages of some of the um
stages you already did in the regular round of eight those those levels just feel like they're
they're making the game like artificially longer by including uh new bosses which are technically old
bosses because you fought the megaman 2 but there's also this weird like you're fighting the megaman 2
bosses but not as themselves but they have the sprites in the game like you watch the sprite of the megaman
2 enemy go into the uh doc robot but then he's like this larger enemy that's like a pain in the ass to dodge
and it's like why couldn't we just fight the megaman 2 uh robot again like that whole section
is is very challenging not even just because um it's it's it prolongs the game and makes it more likely
that you'll you know use up your lives and energy tanks it's more challenging just because i feel like the
the remix stages are harder than the stages we already encountered and the robot masters or doc robot
here is just a harder boss that you have to fight um like eight times before you can get on to the
wily stages yeah i don't know exactly how i feel about it because like sean i really mostly just played
uh the uh the main uh robot master stages but i don't i don't find it an inherent flaw again having not
played all the doc robot stages and i know that well there's two there's two bosses per yeah stage
and four stages there's still eight eight more bosses it's kind of like another megaman game you know
it's like so like i mean i guess i don't hate the idea of there being like three acts in this game
there's the first act which are like the main the main levels then there's the second act which are like
the super powered returning bosses from previous levels and then the third act which is the wily castle
the only thing that kind of bothers me about it is that if you're going to do remix stages of stages
we've already done i know there's a lot to ask but like why don't you just give us four new stages
yeah that's it there like i i i'm all for more content but even just watching the these new
these remix stages like it's not new it's just it's just padding yeah some of some of the level
layouts are almost exact to the point where like the the the room lengths are exactly the same they've
just changed like what's inside of them but uh joe to your point about uh these uh these mid stages
being like an act two it's kind of like megaman's pokemon gold moment where like now they've gone
back to kanto like that you go back to megaman 2 just unfortunate that they didn't include the levels
themselves i guess but i get the premise of just you know revisiting this is probably enough in the
context of this game and using the the design the levels that were designed with the slide
in mind and and the rush power-ups like i understand why it happened i guess i just feel like this this
part slogged a little bit in my in my gameplay of like maybe i just am used to the okay you defeat the
robot masters and then you go fight wily um because like remember wily's castle isn't like one level
it's it's like i think it's five or six stages this time around like that's asking a lot so uh that's
also the point where passwords no longer like save any progress so up until that point the password
system can have you jump back in at any like particular thing of like whichever uh enemies you
encountered or um uh if you're on the uh doc robot stages like which ones of those you took out like
you can save all of that from the moment you fight breakman you can no longer like have a password
that says okay well you made it to like wily castle 3 like i get it it becomes a rush at that stage uh it
just makes for a um a slightly weird pacing but enough about that i feel like we can move on and uh just
talk about i have a quick comment about about this sort of uh i don't even know how to describe it i guess
like progress block or or or sort of like maybe diminishing
maybe a diminishing return what i don't like and i don't know if this was the case in one and two
because i couldn't i can't quite remember but when you die and use it up a life in megaman 3
whatever usage of your power-ups you you did like however much ammunition you used out of your magnet or
whatever like that stays like if you used up all of your power up you no longer have that after dying
um i don't like that at all i think that if i have to restart a level or restart a boss like at least
give me you've already taken away a life of mine like at least give me my ammo back yeah yeah it makes
it all the more challenging yeah yeah i would say on the whole like that that that is a bit of an
anomaly because the rest of the game continues to follow the megaman 2 to 1 trend of making a more
forgiving game there are certainly more of those um giant yellow uh hp uh orbs floating around this
time than there were in two and in one there was practically none or might have even actually been
none i i can't recall right now but like there was it was very hard to recover hp in one two made it a
little more accessible i feel like three has an additional accessibility thing uh as as well in
the energy tanks because those energy tanks are something you can um save within uh your your uh
continues as well so like if you if you game over and you get to the continue screen and you had
like three energy tanks left over you still get to keep all three of those so it does remember
like things in the bad way but it also remembers things in the good way too on game overs sure
it wasn't so much game overs it was like it it was just between lives yeah yeah yeah i hear you
yeah and that bothers me too i think that uh it didn't bother me as much as uh as it could have
because to be honest i didn't run out of power up super super often because i usually just stuck
with the main gun except for the very specific scenarios where i needed other guns you know
yeah like you would save them for the boss fights i suppose that's a less fun game though joe right
like yeah i mean i'm not i wasn't even saving them for the boss fights i think i just often didn't need
them you know i mean like yeah but isn't it just more fun to just like use your stuff you just got
these cool weapons don't you want to use them i used them when i felt like oh this is the spot
where i need this thing but a lot of times it was just maybe this comes down to again like having to
pause the game and select the thing you know it does take you out of down but like a lot of time
say that i i kind of had the same philosophy for like the first half of my playthrough of this where i
was just like i just won't do this i won't use anything at all until i get to the boss because
that's when i have to use this like because it's apparently strong enough on this boss to be
recommended and i would also say go ahead no i just say i don't even know if i was saving it for
bosses i did use the power-ups what felt to me like a lot it was just that like the the main
blaster was but clearly by far my primary weapon and then there were a lot of times where i was like
oh shit like i'm never gonna reach this guy but the snakes can and then i'd use the snakes for a little
while but usually not enough where i'm gonna completely run out of uh the power for that
weapon before i'm on to back to my blaster and then on to something else but it's always very
situational if there wasn't a specific situational reason to use a weapon i was just using the blaster
sure and i guess i was just like oh well now i have enough power-ups that i don't have to like
they all have independent ammunition or or energy i guess so i can screw around with the magnets on
this one or i can use the um i can use the the shadow strike or whatever you call it um and not
have to worry about running out for the boss because that's not the one that it's weak to um but i would
die pretty often and when i thought that the original blaster wasn't quite cutting it and i go in i'm like
oh i can at least get some more like dps out of this thing uh and it's just i'm just still out
because the the ammo drops are are kind of random uh sometimes uh it was it was a weird feeling
yeah the ammo drops being random uh doesn't help but i do feel like especially in sections where they
kind of knew you were going to be using power-ups there's one stage in particular where like it's kind
of implied that you should be using um the rush jet uh to fly across this rather than trying to
platform through it they did scatter like a lot of refills in that in those particular sections to
like be like okay well make sure you keep collecting these so that you keep using this particular power
up in this section i'm not saying that the game is like considerably easier but i did notice that like
even after like in in the boss rush stage uh at the end uh towards the end of wiley's castle
after you defeat each boss they do give you like a large uh hp replenish after each one so you can
just like collect that refill and and take on the next boss rather than trying to like scrape by and
have perfect near perfect runs there was just more like out in the open like you saw more of the
the megaman one-up lives you know like you had to figure out how you were going to reach them but
they were there i feel like the game in general was a little more kind to people who not necessarily
were like willing to explore there's nothing there's no like hidden uh canals or anything but
like more willing to um to spend time with it and and know about these these things the unfortunate
thing is is again if you die while having none of this stuff there isn't like oh well i'll just go
back to this other stage where i know there's plenty of ammo refills and refill up before i take on the new
stage you know you can't do that you can't go backwards
you
qu'
qu' qu'
I don't know about you guys, but that bee who drops down those five bees,
that is nightmare stuff right now.
That's the first enemy I ran into and really like,
oh, this is going to be a fun time.
Then you got the one on the pogo stick or plunger or whatever.
Yeah, yeah. He does like a pole vault.
And you have to do this very specific dodge move just to –
because you can't hit him from the front until – I don't know.
Yeah, until after he vaults.
And then you have to – basically you have to slide under his vault
and then let him run at you, jump over him,
and then shoot him like three times in order to take him out.
And that's just one time.
That's one enemy.
It's not like you're going to, oh, good, I'm glad I got him out of the way.
He's going to do that three more times on that very screen.
Yeah, I feel this way about I think all three of the Mega Man games,
but there are a lot of enemies in them that you need to understand
the pattern that they're going – like their flight path or whatever
before they come at you in order to dodge them.
You can't react.
You have to preemptively react.
Where there are things like on the ceiling,
I'm like, this is going to swoop down at me,
but it swoops down in a trajectory where it's like,
well, I couldn't have predicted that,
and it seemed to predict kind of where I was going to go in a way
where it's like I needed to know it was going to do that beforehand.
I almost feel like I can't just dodge.
The bees were one of them.
Maybe not even that exact circumstance,
but the bees, even the speed runners I'm watching
are getting hit by the bees.
I just feel like you can't dodge those bees.
Well, on that note,
I think a lot of times the most efficient way to move forward
is just to take a hit or two.
There is knockback,
but it's not like a guarantee to throw you down.
It's not Castlevania knockback, yeah.
Yeah, and it's not always a guarantee
that even if you are on kind of like a small platform
that you're going to fall,
it's still very likely that you're going to fall from that knockback
and lose a life and go all the way back.
But if you are smart with it,
you can, like,
that is I think a valid strategy is just take the hit.
Mm-hmm.
And the bees, sorry to stay on them,
but, like, it does feel like there's one singular bee
that drops, like, what, a bunch of larva eggs or something?
Is that what he's holding?
Yeah. And then they break free from that.
It does feel like there should be a moment
where it's like, oh, not a big deal.
I'll shoot the larva before it touches the platform
and breaks open so that I have to deal with five bees.
You cannot do that, for the record.
Don't, I tried a lot of, even with emulation,
like, rewinding and being perfect.
It does not happen.
The bees will come out
and you'll have to deal with all five of them.
And I feel like there are other enemies in this game
that fly and come at you, like those penguins,
but, like, they were much more manageable
than the bees were.
So the bees are just, like,
it's really just because there's a lot of spike deaths
and, or endless platforms and stuff like that.
So it becomes harder.
It's, again, I think to Sean's point,
just tank the hit and move on and it's fine.
Like, they won't be able to chase you
through the entirety of the stage,
but it also, like, slows down the game tremendously.
So it has that going for it in terms of, like,
being on time and jumping over them.
There was some terrible, some terrible slowdown.
Overall, though, like, the Mega Man world,
I know we established that there's no central government
or anything, but, like, the enemies and characters,
like, for the same reasons people love Final Fantasy
or Dragon Quest, like, and the enemies you see in those games,
like, I am starting to appreciate the charm
of the Mega Man world,
not just with the new characters we meet
that become main characters, like Rush and Proto Man,
but, like, those guys who wear the hard hats
and look like Goombas almost, you know,
because they're so small, like, they amuse me now.
They're like the Mega Man world minions.
Yeah, they're cute.
They're cute. I think that we're not at the point yet
where it is, like, self-parody,
but once we get to our place in time,
like, I think that the Mega Man,
like, other mans,
like, the, like, Top Man is already
kind of getting close to, like, this.
What do you mean, Top Man?
Yeah, yeah, where's Bottom Man?
I don't even mean, like,
in any kind of euphemistic way.
It's just, like, you were getting into really
silly things. Yeah, you've run out of, like, elements
and you're onto, like, toy, like,
mini toys. It should be mentioned that the,
just like in Mega Man 2,
the robots here were designed
as part of a contest
that Capcom held
for fans in Japan,
and there was apparently over
50,000 submissions
for ideas for the Robot Masters,
and, yes, somehow Top Man won
as one of those designs.
I don't know, like,
what you got as the grand prize
for being one of the selected things.
It is kind of amazing
that a company was able
to just, like, freelance its workout
for free
to a bunch of kids
to, like, come, I don't know,
you guys come up with the robots,
and they did it.
But I did find,
oddly enough, there was, like,
an eBay auction
maybe back in, like,
I don't know, the 2010s.
I didn't even check the exact date,
but it looks pretty old
and expired of a guy
who sold
his runner-up
pencil tin
and ID card
that Capcom shipped to him
as, like, your design wasn't selected,
but you're awesome,
and we love your idea,
so we gave you
an ID card
and a pencil tin,
and unfortunately...
What is the ID card?
The ID card is in Japanese,
so I don't know exactly what it says,
but oddly enough...
Does it grant you entry to Capcom?
No, it doesn't,
but here's something interesting.
So it's an ID card,
and you designed
a robot master,
so, of course,
who would be,
like, who would be authorizing you?
Yeah, you're Dr. Wily.
You're one of his... Dr. Wily, yes, exactly.
You're his minions.
Yeah, the bad guy here
is thanking you
for helping him
create another robot master
to take down Mega Man.
Cute, though,
Mega Man is on the...
Even the guy saved the envelope.
That it came in in the mail,
and Mega Man is on the envelope
along with Capcom
and their official address
and everything, so it's kind of sad
that, like, Capcom won't revisit,
like, who is basically their mascot
at this point in time.
Like, they won't revisit this guy,
but they're happy to just keep churning out
Monster Hunter games,
which don't interest me at all,
but clearly make a lot of money
for the company. You know,
or, like, I don't know, Sean,
Resident Evil, like,
is Leon,
like, the main person
that should be the mascot of Capcom,
or is that, like, no?
I mean, I don't have the same...
I don't have the same problem
because I don't have
any kind of emotional connection
to Mega Man,
and I do
with Resident Evil,
so I'm pretty okay with it.
I also don't care about
Monster Hunter, though.
But I guess which Resident Evil
person should be, like,
the mascot? Obviously,
hyper-buff
Chris Redfield
with biceps
larger than his head.
Let it be written...
Biceps larger than twice his head.
Sorry to interrupt
Sorry to interrupt!
Sorry to interrupt!!
So, you know, just real fast, because we're talking about the contest.
Top Man, obviously, is the funny one, but Shadow Man, Spark Man, Magnet Man, Hard Man, Gemini Man, Needle Man, Snake Man.
You know, I feel like for what it's worth, I understand that a competition that receives 50,000 submissions generates a lot of great buzz for Capcom and potential sales and everything.
But Capcom totally could have also just came up with these same villains, right?
Like, it didn't require the masses to be like, we're out of ideas, we need your help.
Like, to our point, it's the third Mega Man game.
You still have elements you can use.
You have, like, you know, there's an endless, we know it.
There's up to 10 Mega Mans and all those Mega Man X games.
Like, we know there are others.
But here, they're already asking for help.
Yeah, there is something very alluring to me about the idea of, like, being a kid.
And, you know, games that I liked, I would design my own games, like, on a piece of paper with colored pencils, you know?
So the idea that, like, just the imagination involved in, like, oh, like, people just made these.
Like, you can make a Mega Man, what are they called?
Bad Robot Master.
Yeah. No, what are these enemies called?
The Robot Masters.
You can make a Robot Master, like, out of anything you can think of.
Like, that's just cool to me.
You know, yeah, obviously you're right.
Like, they didn't need to do this.
But I think you said it.
It's a PR thing.
And it seems to have been effective.
I actually do like the idea more that if it was, like, guys, we're totally out of ideas.
We really need help.
They were in crunch.
They were obviously in crunch.
They make these games once a year and there's a team of, like, six people making them.
It's almost like it's going to be harder.
Where it's like, oh, yeah, we got to pick.
Now we have to design things based off of something someone else came up with.
We have to design, like, gameplay around it.
But while we're talking about the design of these things, I do want to also just say I really, just all the enemies, everyone, everything on screen, like, in a regular stage, I just, I really like it.
Like, they're so silly, but so cool and still kind of scary, like, at the same time.
And it's just like it all, they should not, all three of those things shouldn't fit together so well, but they do.
I really appreciate the design of all these Mega Man games.
Yeah, at the very least, you can say that it's too many enemies on a screen or that the enemies are really hard or whatever.
But, like, it is also, like, thoughtful enemy design in the sense of, like, how each enemy is completely different from each other.
Yeah, it's not just, like, a different skin shade than every other enemy that you fought.
And they just come at you and run at you.
Exactly, yeah.
They have mechanics. So the pole vaulting guy sucks, but it's also, like, really cleverly designed.
Yeah. We were, you were talking about contests, Joe, and I just wanted to mention the two that I know of, which is, I think, Nintendo held it for Legend of Zelda Link to the Past.
They're the winner of a contest, I think, in the power, maybe something else, was in, like, a secret house that you could get into.
And his name would be in the game, so he was literally in The Legend of Zelda.
And you know this one, but I'll tell the listeners.
There's also the boss, the secret boss in Kingdom Hearts 1, Kurt Ziza, which sounds like a villain to begin with.
Yes. Like, they couldn't have. And thank God the guy's name was Kurt Ziza and not, like, Jim Smith.
Right, exactly. Like, I'm fighting Jim Smith.
But, like, Kurt Ziza, like, I didn't know what a Kurt Ziza was.
Yeah, right. I didn't think it was a person.
Wait, what is this? But I also don't, you gotta look up Kurt Ziza Kingdom Hearts because.
It's like a snake in robo-armor, kind of, with sword, not robo-armor.
But this was, this was something that they planned to make based off of a fan.
Well, I think they already made the enemy.
I don't think they, like, waited to find out who won.
Okay. Yeah. The fan just happened to be a snake in armor with swords.
40 snakes, yeah. Yeah, perfect.
But when I was a kid, I just have to say about Kurt Ziza.
Like, I didn't know that it was a fan contest.
And I just remember, like, I didn't, my brain didn't read Kurt as the name Kurt.
Yes, I still don't.
To this day, I don't do that.
I just read it as, like, one thing, Kurt Ziza.
Yeah. And when I, like, learned about that, I was like, oh, of course, Kurt, that's a name.
But, like, it didn't read that way to me because it just sounds like such a Final Fantasy Kingdom Hearts enemy name, you know?
Yeah, well, Kurt is a good name because think about it.
To your point about John Smith or whatever, even if it was just John Ziza, like, that doesn't cut it for me.
That's not. Yeah, right. John is too popular.
Kurt does feel like an attack even, like something that might slice you.
Don't get Kurted.
Yeah. Like a Mike Ziza.
Yeah, Mike Ziza is not doing anything other than making pizzerias.
Yeah. I'm sorry, guys, but none of the three of us have names that would work as an enemy in a Squaresoft game.
I agree. I agree 100%.
Okay, moving on, because we probably should.
Back on track to the Wily Fortress.
Just want to talk about some of the bosses in there.
We don't have to do, like, comprehensive or anything, but I need to tell you where I lost my Mega Man 3 mojo.
And that was with a good old friend, the Yellow Devil.
He's back. He's the Yellow Devil Mark 2.
And he's basically the same idea, if you think about it.
Like, he looks different, sure.
And he behaves, like, kind of the same way where he moves from block from block, one side of the screen to the other.
And I know there's a pattern.
And I know you can learn it.
I cannot learn it fast enough before I get hit.
And I wish I could have been that guy who said I overcame it in time for the podcast.
But I could not beat the Yellow Devil.
I would have maybe tried a little harder if I could have, like, died and went right back to, like, fighting him.
Like, the room right before him, and you just go right back in.
But you have to do the whole level over again, too.
Which is a short level, but it's just, like, it was just asking too much.
I wasn't going to be able to figure out the pattern.
So, from that moment on, it did become a Game Genie moment.
But the Yellow Devil just remains inaccessible to me when he appears in these games.
Because he was tough the first time.
He's tougher now.
Or maybe not.
Because, like, the slide adds an interesting mechanic where you can slide under these.
I just think there's not enough room in the fight for me to be, like, able to take these hits.
Because, like, when you get hit by a block, it's not like, oh, okay, I just can't have that happen 12 more times.
It's like, it's taking off chunks of your damage, of your health.
So, you have to make sure that, like, you learn this pattern quickly.
Yeah, and then I don't remember in the other games, like, the pieces of him do different patterns now.
They, like, bounce. And they, like, they don't just slide across the screen anymore.
Yep. And there's a weird, like, glitch thing there where, if they're in the blobby form, if you are hanging out on the other side that he's not on,
you'll take, like, massive damage for being on that side where he's going to, like, spawn in.
And I'm like, well, that doesn't, you know, I shouldn't know that.
Like, there's nothing over there currently.
Yeah, and I just, I don't want to assume, I usually am under the assumption that everyone listening to this knows more about these games than I do.
But just for the, just for the sake of, uh, of, uh, caution, if anyone doesn't know what the Yellow Devil is,
it's this, this giant enemy that's maybe, you know, 20 times the, the sprite size of Mega Man.
And each little cube 20th sprite, each little, like, portion of his sprite breaks off from him and shoots across the screen one at a time that you have to dodge.
And that's just in between its attacks.
So, like, not only are you fighting him, but, like, every couple seconds you have to, like, wait while he transitions to the other side of the screen and avoid all of those, too.
So, it's like you're in kind of two fights at once.
All while, and this is gonna, I'm just gonna, like, shove my nitpicks into this section right here.
All while there is some very questionable hitbox stuff going on, um, and maybe some input eating.
I don't know how you guys felt about these specific complaints, but I felt like your hitbox against a lot of enemies was larger than your sprite.
And, uh, I would, like, input to turn around to shoot, and I, it would eat my turn around input, and I'd be shooting in the opposite direction.
Uh, yeah, that happens.
So, these are things that happen playing this game, so it's not always your fault when you, when you get hit, and, or, uh, you know, fail to take advantage of an opening.
And sometimes that, that hurts.
Yeah, and, and I don't want to say that, like, the Yellow Devil is impossible.
I just don't think I had the, the time commitment, uh, to make it beyond that.
Because what's interesting is, the Yellow Devil is pretty early on in Wily's castle, and he's tough.
After that, you have to fight, uh, these Mega Man holograms, which are also, like, a tough enemy if you don't understand that, like, oh, only one of them is the real Mega Man hologram.
Which is like, wait, that's not how that works, because I'm the real Mega Man, so why are the, why are there, like, what is this?
Like, one of them is also the real Mega Man, and the other two are holograms, or are they all three holograms?
Anyway, that one's a, a, a challenging boss, because they kind of, like, appear from their hologram base, they run to the left, shoot like crazy, all three of them at the same time.
And, homing at you, uh, all three of them, and then they run to the right, and they shoot some stuff, and then they go back to their hologram base, and, and then you have to, like, oh, I don't know which one.
The real one's the real one anymore, because now they'll appear.
So you kind of have to do some guesswork.
But if you have the snake power-up, and you knew that, you can actually take out the real Mega Man in, in, uh, one sequence, because the snake thing, like, will do enough damage if you shoot it, if you just spam it, uh, before he goes back in the hologram tube.
So that one's, like, okay, at least there's, like, a cheese method.
I, I, there's no cheese method to Yellow Devil, you just have to be able to survive, uh, at least three sequences of him doing that, like, block-to-block thing.
The, after the holograms is the boss rush of every single robot master in Mega Man 3.
Not the Mega Man 2 ones again, but the Mega Man 3 ones.
And I gotta say, like, it's nice that this time you don't have to do all of the bosses and then immediately fight Dr.
Wily. I think that was true in Mega Man 2.
Uh, but this is, this is still not good.
I feel like I complained about this on Mega Man 2, I hope I did, uh, but I don't think that this is great design.
To be like, okay, the whole beginning of the game was go through their stage, find the robot master, take them down to get, I don't know, what are they collecting here?
It says it in the manual, they're collecting some kind of energy.
Elements? They're connecting, uh, energy crystals.
Uh, so you, you collect those, right?
That's what, that's what the whole point is, and then Wily runs off with them after you collected them.
So why are they back?
And why is it just them, like, instead of, like...
Because Wily rebuilt them with his own...
I know, I know, but like, it's like we are, it's treading ground we already did.
You know what I'm saying? And now it's just like, oh, we'll do it all in the same sequence.
Uh, I just don't like that, but it is, you know, to, to add to the challenge.
It's a, it's a tough challenge, but now you know their weaknesses, presumably, and you'll be able to deal with them without losing too much health.
And they give you health, uh, after you defeat each of them, so you could theoretically, like, even if you have a bad fight against one, you could have two good fights and go back to full health.
And like I said, you don't have to fight Dr.
Wily at the end of this boss rush, so it's not, uh, as challenging as it once was.
Still padding. Yep, still padding.
I totally agree with you.
Then you fight Dr.
Wily in his, uh, new Wily machine.
I don't know. I'm sure these things have a more official name, but, uh, it's the third iteration of this.
And, uh, this is where it almost just becomes that moment in the game where like, if you got to this point, you're fine.
You know, like now it's all like cinema flair and just like, let's wrap up this story because, and I'm sure there'll be some people that disagree with me, but Wily's a pretty easy fight.
And after him, uh, you fight Gamma with Wily and, uh, controlling him.
Gamma, by the way, for plot point is just like, he's supposed to be like the one robot that will protect the world.
And it's just like, I don't think we should ever be building a giant robot to protect us.
Uh, especially if we have all these robots that go bad, uh, in this world, we shouldn't be building more of them, but they did that.
Every single one. Yeah.
Like every single one.
Ever in the history of the universe.
Right. Uh, and so he comes out with this awesome sprite where, um, you know, he takes up the entire screen.
He's kind of like in the background, but his stage again, it's, it's, it's just a boss fight.
It's pretty easy.
If you know the weakness, you could take him down in two shots.
And finally the, uh, top spin power up is, is useful because if you, uh, do get to the second phase of the gamma boss fight and, uh, top spin on top of his head,
it's an automatic KO.
So what a cool way to finish, uh, the game by just doing a little, oh yeah, well how about this?
And tornado spinning on his head.
A little finishing touch.
I mean, you know, after that, it's all story beats.
We find out, um, that proto man is mega man's brother.
Hmm. That's interesting.
I wouldn't know. I, uh, I wasn't really sure it was happening.
Yeah. So it's his brother, which they kind of tease us with.
They also do like a credits list.
They're like number, um, the number of the robots.
So now we have like number eight, elect man, number nine.
Right. But it's like, it gives, it gives those ones like their purpose and everything.
But then eventually like with the other robots, it gives them like the name and then like another
name. And I was like, who's, is that like the actor?
Yeah. Like who, I couldn't find a solid answer.
I'm sure it's just somebody who worked on the game, but I'm like, why are they being paired
with these? And then I was like, oh, you know what?
Maybe it's the winners of the contest.
Oh, okay. That makes sense.
I couldn't confirm it.
I couldn't confirm it, but I have to think like, that's the most likely thing is that it
is what it designed. I do like the idea of just making up an actor name.
Yeah. Well, because remember, I think, I'm pretty sure, didn't Castlevania do that?
The original? Yeah.
I've never seen the ending organically, but.
I forgot about that.
Yeah. Also a neat little thing here at the end of Mega Man 3, after you learn that Proto Man's
your brother and everything, you see him in the sky.
But if you look to your right, you will also see a little UFO.
Oh, and that is probably Dr.
Wiley's hinting that he is not gone and he will return.
Who would have thought?
Who would have thought they would make Mega Man 4?
I would think.
Yeah. They've made up to 11 now, right?
I actually don't know.
I feel like 11 came out, like, 9 and 10 were still like NES inspired, even though they
came out like on the Wii or something like that.
But 11 is like a more modern, like, faithful thing, but made by Capcom.
Well, it's pretty crazy to me that we're going to have six of these by 1992 and then only
11 by 2025.
Yeah, right? Like, what happened to the pace?
But you have to remember, then they jump over to the X series, Joe, and there were eight
of those. Oh, okay.
So those still are Mega Man series.
Yeah, and then there was, there was like, um, alphas, Mega Man alphas as well.
And then the 3D one where you can like kick a can.
Sure. There's also Mega Man soccer on the Super Nintendo.
I don't know why they made that.
That really is a thing.
Oh, wow. Yeah, I wish I was joking.
But to give some development context here for just Mega Man 3, the development began, like,
pretty much immediately after Mega Man 2.
And the lead supervisor of the first two games, Akira Kitamura, quit in like, I guess like
in the middle of this game or like, maybe like in the early weeks of it.
But, uh, they basically had to like, figure out how to do this without the guy who had
been making them.
Uh, so it's already a tight team.
That's why they hired out those kids.
Right, right, right. And, um, Inafune, who's the artist who create, uh, who's credited with a lot of Mega Man success.
Uh, he said that Mega Man 3 is one of his least favorite entries in the series, um, due
to what went into the game and what was behind the release of the game.
So that just sounds like maybe a lot of infighting about what Mega Man 3 should be.
Yeah, exactly. Stuff that like, he's like not going to tell us, but he kind of told us everything by saying
that. He didn't like the kids.
Yeah. Um, but I don't know.
I don't feel like, like this is a rushed, unfinished game.
It's bigger than the other ones.
Like it's, it's even, they could just continue expanding the scope.
Yeah, it definitely has a polish to it.
You know, I, I, you know, it's, it's in that high percentile of all NES games by, by far,
as far as like polish and completeness.
Yeah. I feel like there's usually some kind of like telling mark that like, oh, this game, this
game went through, there were a lot of arguments, there were some falling outs.
Uh, I think it's more noticeable in like, I think it may be like the, uh, I don't know.
If you watch, if you watch like what happened, like on YouTube, one of, that's one of my favorite
YouTube series about like just games and some movies that have really troubled, uh, really
troubled production timelines and stories.
Uh, usually you can tell like that this game is like kind of the committee that designed it
didn't really like each other.
And this doesn't really have any of those hallmarks.
Right. And, um, this is more, this isn't like development context, but, uh, like left in the game, there's
a lot that you can do if you plug in a second controller while playing Mega Man three that
probably wasn't like intended to, it was probably like debugging code for the game, uh, because
it's completely removed in the European version, uh, which I, I've got to imagine came out afterwards.
It wasn't like, uh, Oh, stop the presses.
It's like, we'll, we'll spend a couple extra days.
It was like the controller two.
If you hold the right on the D pad, the right button on the D pad, it gives Mega Man a super
jump. Uh, even allowing Mega Man to jump out of pits and such like he can just jump almost the
entire height of the screen.
If you hold up, it will slow down the animations.
And if you hold up and a, it will freeze the timer on some of the animations.
So not like the, there's no like in game clock or whatever, but like the timing on some of
the animations, including like no, yeah, enemy attacks and explosions and other things.
Um, so it, it, it, it even causes like some bosses to just like freeze in place.
So, um, if you, if you haven't tried that plug in a second controller.
All right. That, that sounds like something that would happen to a game with a, uh, rough design schedule.
Yeah. But again, like, would you ever think to plug in a second controller on a one player game?
No. Should Mega Man three have had a battle mode where you, you and, uh, one of you plays as
Mega Man, one of you plays as Proto Man and you have all the power ups and you just like
shoot at each other in an, in an arena.
No, that's kind of just what the Proto Man battles are.
Right. I do love that.
I think it is online.
Like journey. You don't know you're online.
Spoiler. I think I ever played it.
Wow. Huge spoiler.
Um, but probably not now.
I mean, is anyone online playing journey right now?
I'm just, it's like, to be fair.
I never played it. So I'm just guessing.
So it's really not a spoiler.
It's a theory that I have.
Well, we'll go on that journey together, Joe.
I love it. You can't, you can't do that.
The PlayStation one version of this game, which exists, apparently I had no idea.
Um, it rock man complete works.
So that makes me think it's a Japanese only, uh, game, but it added a, uh, what was called
a Navi mode, I guess, navigational mode, uh, which added onscreen hint pop-ups.
Um, which I can only imagine must be incredibly annoying.
Yeah. Right. Like, like how, what could it have done other than been like, use this weapon on this boss,
right? Like, like it's, there's not a lot of like, you know, Oh, watch your, watch your step.
Right. Like you don't need something like that.
Uh, but again, just another thing that from soft stole from earlier video games.
And, uh, these, these features were added to the mega man anniversary collection.
So maybe I should look at, um, playing like the, the baby mode, uh, with my copy.
Yeah. I could use, I could definitely use a baby mode for these games.
I feel like I also heard though, um, that there was like extreme lag on the anniversary
collection on PS2.
So maybe that's why I was so bad at those games.
What could possibly make a PS2 game lag an NES game?
I don't know what made a PS1 disc.
Why did a PS1 disc make Chrono Trigger lag?
Why did the chicken cross the road?
Oh, actually, you know what? Yeah, Joe, you're right.
It was the load times, not actual lagging.
And also like, would it matter if things lagged in a turn-based game?
Uh, anyway, um, it's some, some questions.
Okay. Which single mechanic makes mega man three feel the most different from mega man two?
The slide, the new friendly dog or the doc robot stages?
The slide. Uh, see, I might, I might, uh, play devil's advocate here and say, uh, I think maybe the
doc robot stages, the slide does, but I feel like honestly, it didn't, it having not played
the other ones in a while, I was not like, oh my God, this is so different.
I actually had to remember, but yeah, wait, was there a slide in mega man two or not?
So like, it definitely does make a difference, but I don't think it was like, uh, I don't
think it was as significant as there being eight more bosses, you know, granted now just
to argue with myself here, you don't even have to talk.
I'll just argue with myself.
Um, granted that the fact that they are taking previous bosses, maybe just by definition
makes it more like the previous games and not more, uh, separate.
So who knows?
I mean, my argument against that is that, uh, some people would never even notice that they're,
that those bosses exist because they don't get to them.
They don't get to them, uh, which is, uh, me.
Um, but, uh, so I'm gonna, I'm gonna stick with the, I'm gonna stick with the slide to
me. It's like, you know, like you, you can obviously, you can automatically tell the difference
between, uh, between like Tony Hawk pro skater two and Tony Hawk pro skater three, because
in Tony Hawk pro skater three, you had the revert.
And that means you could like, you could have these really crazy long, like combos going.
And I could be wrong.
And maybe that was into, but, uh, but like it, it's something foundational and like that
slide is like a foundational move that you're going to either use all the time or completely
forget about, but it's still like, it's a part of your move set.
Yeah. I'm, I'm sold.
I, I rescind.
Sorry.
What one change would you make in a Mega Man 3 remaster without losing the NES feel?
Hmm. I might make my Proto Man change.
Give him some power-ups of his own.
Should he have new power-ups you've never seen, or should he have callback power-ups?
What are you thinking?
I like new power-ups you've never seen, only because I like the idea of there being these unobtainable things that he's doing.
He's on his own alternate journey.
He's an alternate version of you.
He's got totally different things.
Maybe if you really want to make the game development a little more complicated, give him one power-up that counters each of your power-ups in some way.
It's kind of interesting that we've never had a Final Fantasy game where halfway through we run into the other group that's questing to take down...
Yeah, we had the same plan over in our town.
We defeated this boss already.
We're planning to do this.
It's like, oh, you guys want to team up?
And they're like, no, we want to stop you, too.
There's got to be a Final Fantasy that has that.
Maybe not a Final Fantasy, but definitely an RPG has to have that mechanic in it somewhere.
Because that's just really fun. That's a fun idea.
I agree with you.
I like the Proto Man one.
Sean, not to put you on the spot, but can you top it?
No, I don't have any.
I think it would be a multitude of changes.
Yeah, I hear you.
I hear you. But also, I feel like you did call out your biggest complaint was about the ammunition not replenishing between deaths.
And maybe that's a simple enough fix to slap a remaster on it.
It's now easier.
There you go.
Yeah, and I didn't think about the question either, if I'm being honest.
But in terms of what I would want to see now while still keeping the NES feel, I think you can just release the same game.
But let's give these games the pixel remaster treatment where you can kind of tweak them as necessary.
Like, okay, enemies do 0.5 times damage now.
And you just turn that setting on and you go through the game and you're able to experience it.
But it's kind of like, you know what you did.
You went into the settings and you had to change those things.
There's no, like, easy mode.
But you have to live with that.
It's the same thing with turning experience points up four times on any of the Final Fantasy pixel remasters.
I'm going to be able to sleep at night doing that because I have now gained enough time to go to sleep.
If I did the one-time experience, I would be still playing to make up the same amount of time as the four times.
So I'm fine with it. I think a lot of games, not even just NES games, but a lot of older games,
could benefit from just, like, this settings menu where you kind of, like, adjust the feel of, like,
especially for JRPGs, how often turn-based encounters happen.
Do they happen at all?
Like, you know, I'm not saying change the system where, like, it scales with you or something.
God, no. Please don't do that.
I have one now.
Please. Blood and gore.
Why not? It's Mega Man.
Yeah, have, like, a blood and gore slider.
You can go from, like, none, like, default, and then, like, truly, like, gib-tastic, like,
super meat boy stuff on all the walls and stuff.
Would it be blood or would it be oil?
Oh, you're right.
It's like oil and gore.
I think that you should still keep the graphics just pixelated, you know,
exactly the same graphics but have, like, fully, like, Unreal Engine 5 blood and gore coming out of it.
Yeah, I'm going to do it. The Japanese subtitle of Mega Man 3 was Dr.
Wily no Saigo, which means the end of Dr.
Wily. So I guess they were trying to, like, fake out a trilogy here, but I don't think anyone thought
that this was, like, the end of a trilogy.
But you could make the case that, like, Mega Man 1, Dr.
Light and Dr. Wily are working together,
and Dr. Wily betrays Dr.
Light, and then you have that.
In Mega Man 2, now Wily's acting on his own.
So, you know, you've got to take him down with the new robots he created without the help of Dr.
Light. And now, at the end of the trilogy, Wily's back with Light, but only to betray him again.
But that's not really, like, I don't know, that's just, like, a repeat of the story of one a little bit,
except for now you already know that he did the betraying.
Yeah, that sounds a little, like, daytime TV.
Maybe that's exactly what Mega Man was made for, a little telenovela.
It's a will they, won't they with Dr.
Light and Dr. Wily.
Will they get back together?
Yeah, they should have, like, between each level had sort of, like, a B plot that went over, like, their little love affair.
Yeah, just seeing them, like, out to dinner, and, you know, Dr.
Wily's like, what do you say we play credit card roulette to decide who pays for the bill?
Do they have credit cards in Mega Man?
I don't think there's money.
Yeah, there's no money either.
That's so interesting. There's three things, that's it.
Robots, people, and robot dogs.
Yes. But that begs the question, are there dogs in the Mega Man world?
No. Just robot dogs?
Yeah. Yep.
Maybe they're in, like, a simulation.
Maybe Dr. Light and Dr.
Wily went inside a computer.
Well, yes, of course they are, right?
Is it a simulation, though, or, like, just inside of a program?
Well, we are in a simulation, so.
And they're in our program.
Right. They're in a simulation. Got it.
Okay, that's all my stuff.
I just wanted to mention real fast, since I was talking about the anniversary collection.
There is one other way to, like, play these in the old-fashioned way, and that is with
the Sega Genesis release of The Wily Wars.
The Wily Wars.
It only came out on Genesis.
The Wily Wars?
Yeah, The Wily Wars.
And it remakes Mega Man's 1, 2, and 3 with a 16-bit art style.
But apparently, also, like, some different physics and stuff, too.
So, I'm curious.
Like, are The Wily Wars, like, panned?
Like, do they not feel like Mega Man?
Or is it, like, a slept-on thing where it's like, oh, a lot of people just don't know about
it? And turns out, like, that, like, just like how Super Mario All-Stars doesn't, like, replace
Super Mario Bros.
1, 2, and 3 on the NES.
It kind of, like, is like, well, I prefer to play it on Super Nintendo with All-Stars.
Or, no, I prefer to play it on the NES, like, the way it was intended.
Interesting conversation. I don't have an opinion, because I've never played Wily Wars.
But I do have an opinion on something, Sean.
And that is if Mega Man 3 will be on the Essential Games list.
For me, Mega Man 3 is the tightest Mega Man yet.
Mega Man 2, while a great game, Mega Man 3 felt more accessible, more dynamic, and the
new mechanics that were added, the slide, Rush, and the Doc Robot stages, are all, like,
even if I don't love the length of the Doc Robot stages, they're all, like, welcome things
in terms of expanding Mega Man.
They all make it feel like a bigger game.
I don't feel like this game is unfinished or, like, a decline in the series.
I feel like the slide isn't just, like, a gimmick thing.
It feels like it's part of Mega Man, which makes it, like I said, it will be interesting
to go back to 1 or 2.
And I know I said it on Mega Man 2's episode, but now I really question both 1 and 2 being
on the Essential Games list, and especially 1, obviously, when 3 can get the job done.
1. I think it will just be about, though, like, Mega Man 3 and 2 are kind of, like, the same
exact engine, the same game, so they're almost, like, complements to each other.
Do you just have to, like, suck it up and put 1?
Like, are we in a situation where we need to do that?
Or can we just agree that, like, both are great?
Like, that's a discussion we'll have later.
Today is all about Mega Man 3, and I'm happy to say that even though I think this game is
still just as hard, the accessibility features that they added and just the kind of, like,
the way that it flows as you move on, not becoming, like, this increasingly more challenging
thing, but just kind of this thing that, like, well, if you made it this far, you can probably
persevere feels better than what was happening with Mega Man 1 and 2, where it was like,
yeah, you're lucky to be here, and you'll be lucky to get any further.
I appreciated this change of pace in Mega Man 3, and so I'm giving it my Essential Games
List stamp. What about you, Joe?
I think that the Mega Man series, just talking about all three of them right now, they're still
the goat when it comes to power-ups.
Just their ability to keep things balanced in a way where, like, everything that you get
is useful.
You get tons of power-ups.
They're all very, well, mostly very helpful, very useful in different scenarios, but you
never feel overpowered.
It still feels like a challenge in that, like, there are specific things that are being balanced.
There's bosses and enemies that are being balanced where you can beat it without these things
or with them.
Like, that's quite the feat, in my opinion, to design something like that.
I feel like this episode, we have sounded maybe a little negative.
I'll be honest, I thought that, Mike, I thought you were not going to vote at Essential, just
based on the episode so far.
I thought that, and maybe, you know, Sean will have a chance to prove this right or wrong
on his episode, but I thought I was going to be a lone Essential vote for this one.
But I really did enjoy it.
I haven't played the other two in a long time.
So in my flawed memories of two, I guess I vaguely remember maybe liking two a little
more, but I do firmly believe that, like, there's no need for, like, only one game existing
on this, you know, in this series existing on the Essential Games list.
I think that if all three games are fantastic games that are worth playing, then all three
games are Essential Games.
So what I'm bringing it down to is, like, if somebody asks me, hey, I'm into video games,
should I play Mega Man 3?
What is my answer going to be?
My answer is going to be definitely for Mega Man 1, 2, and 3, at least before I do a revisit
of them. That's where I stand for now.
So right now, I still, I'm going to give my Essential vote for three different games.
I think 1, 2, and 3 are essential.
All right, Sean.
Okay, yeah. So I, like, I mentioned earlier that I revisited our past, at least our Essential Games list
sections for Mega Man 1 and 2, just so that I could recalibrate where my head has been
these past hard for many years.
And I think it's because, like, I don't know, I think my mood has just shifted.
Like, I think I have less patience now, because I didn't really, I didn't have all that much
fun playing this game.
And I know that I did in 1 and 2, but does that mean, does that mean that, like, this
isn't essential? Because, like, it's just not really my cup of tea right now?
Because it really isn't.
But, like, it's sort of like, you know, when I talk about football and, you know, there
was a time in my life where I would have just said, like, you know, no, no, no, Tom Brady
sucks. Tom Brady is a system QB, and it's all Bill Belichick.
And, like, there's nothing that he's got that you couldn't plug anybody else in.
And he'd win just as many Super Bowls.
But, you know, looking back on stuff, and, you know, he then won another Super Bowl somewhere
else, and then Bill Belichick wasn't very good.
I'm getting off topic.
Basically, it's more so, like, you have to visually, like, I visually see objectively that
this is just an improvement on two games that I voted essential.
That is, like, that is what this is.
Like, there's no way that this is a worse game than those two.
I just didn't, you know, I just, like, I'm at the point in, I'm at a point in time where
it's just, I didn't really have that much fun with it.
But, you know, as, like, an objective observer, I'm just going to say, yeah, it's essential.
I'm concurring. Like, I'm not going to argue about it.
I do think you bring up a good point, though, about one specific thing, and that is the
enjoyment that you are having as somebody who is playing through all of these NES games
with limited time, you know, like, we release an episode every Friday.
Like, it's hard to, like, pick up a franchise that you last touched years ago, right?
Like, Mega Man 2 was a while back now.
And it's hard to also just, like, keep switching gears and being good at these things.
And Mega Man games in general require them to, you have to be good at them to have fun.
You are otherwise learning how to play the game.
I think that's worth mentioning, that Mega Man 3 and Mega Man 2, and Mega Man 2 actually
had, like, an easy mode, if you recall.
It had, like, a, they called it normal mode, but you could also play difficult mode.
So, that one even had, like, a toned down version thing.
Mega Man 1 was the hardest of the batch, no question.
But, like, even if these games become more accessible, that's from the viewpoint of, like,
changing things within the design of Mega Man games to kind of, like, tone them down.
They're still Mega Man games.
They're still challenging. Compared to the games that we play nowadays where, like, basically everyone wins as long
as they're willing to play, right?
Like, I can't think of somebody who wouldn't be able to finish God of War 2018 if they just
wanted to play it.
Like, they're never going to get stuck in, like, that boss is too hard.
Like, it's basically like watching a story.
Mega Man is not that kind of series.
And so, yeah, if you're, like, picking it up and going through it and dying a lot, like,
Joe even joked in the episode that his Mega Man is the one that explodes all the time.
Like, yeah, that happens, but that has to also be, like, a rewarding thing, too.
And I think that's what Mega Man gets right is that, like, you'll die, I don't know, you
know, 20, 30 times or whatever.
But, like, you'll get better along the way.
This isn't, there's no cheap shots in this game.
There are things that might feel unavoidable or that you personally just can't overcome.
For me, that happened to be Yellow Devil.
But on an infinite timescale, like, everything on Mega Man is very achievable in the sense
of, like, what NES games are offering.
There are tons of really cheap or needlessly hard NES games.
This is just one that requires more, like, patience to love.
Yeah. I also, I was going to mention something similar when we were talking about the, um, kind of
the artificially drawn-out length of the game, which I don't disagree with.
I do think that, like, yeah, having the, the, those extra levels, but having them not
be new levels does make it feel a little artificial.
But it probably is an easier pill to swallow when you're playing this game.
You're picking it up and putting it down over, like, years as a child, as opposed to us where
we're, like, yeah, we got, we got six days to play.
You know, obviously we start sometimes a little before the week before, but, like, still, it's,
like, it's just a thing that's, there is a time limit where we're, like, we got to get
as far as we can in this amount of time, as opposed to, like, yeah, if this is just the
game that I had for the year, you know, one of my two or three video games, then it would
be, like, yeah, this is how far I am, and, you know, I'm going to put it down for a few
months. I'm going to pick it back up eventually, you know.
And that's sort of, that's sort of my, it's, it's all, it's just also being kind of, like,
trying to have some internal consistency.
But, like, I know I have used the defense in a lot of games that we have talked about
difficulty in a negative sense of just, like, well, if I actually had more time, this would
be, like, I'd find this a lot more satisfying, and the word I am looking for eludes me, but
fulfilling. Whereas, you know, it's just, the time crunch kind of takes the magic out of it sometimes,
but I still like doing it.
Yeah, and without spoiling it, I do know what the change is in Mega Man 4.
Do you guys?
No. I don't. Okay, cool.
So, I won't spoil it here.
Is it online, secretly? It's, yeah, it's always online.
He's barefoot now.
Oh, that would be a twist, right?
He takes, he takes off the blaster.
He just fights with his fists now.
It's actually Samus underneath all the armor.
Samus versus Mega Man is, like, something that people didn't really make a big deal out of
on Smash Brothers when they finally were both in the same game, right?
Like, I feel like Mega Man Mario wasn't really, like, Mario's got Sonic.
Yeah. Mega Man should be going off against Samus, I suppose.
Or Samus against Simon or whatever, right?
Or who, who's, who'd they put in for, did they put in Simon or did they put in Trevor?
I think it's Simon. Good.
Okay, no, I can't remember.
I was, it's weird is, is like, I played Smash for, like, the longest time, and somehow
DLC ruined it for me.
Like, I stopped playing when they started doing those season pass things, and now I can't
remember, like, any of the 87 people that are in Smash Brothers other than Mario and Yoshi.
Is that one soccer player in it now?
Oh, Ronaldo?
Yeah, Ronaldo, he's in it, right?
Yeah, he's, he's, well, he's in Fortnite, and I heard that just the concept of Fortnite
is going to be the next character in Smash Brothers.
After Home Depot.
Home Depot for Smash 7 confirmed.